E
, ONUTFRONT" NOWE FOER
OA.KESPERS-RIGHT
HE QUIS D ARST GROUPS ING
RH FROM CAL FIGURES ON TWITTER
IOKEN TYOU HAVE BEE THAT ASOLEC
HG AN
CONCERNYOU?
MOREHAE THE  WHO HAT CONCERNS ME
SEEM TO HAVE SHIFTED T FOCUS
G EVENTS AND PROTESTING
LGBTQ+E
THE MEND OF ON
NDATNA
ORGANIZEGROUPS.
OF THE F THA
Y 6th INSURREC. REALLSTDANGERF
BECAROUPE
FAIRLY GOOELNDYIE THAT MAY
NOT BE, YOU KNOW, THATAY
MORE APT T VIOLENTIO
KIND OF OUT OF THE AREA.BUT, YOB
ORGANIC GATHERING OPEOPHA CTLY.
CHOOSINGF WA KFFN.
YO, I' CONCERNED.
TONIGHT.ABOUT
CHANGE.
THSIONS AND
HIEVBUT CURRENTLY THE LI S PRET
TIED HAVE
SEPARATEPLE IENOW BEGROUPS, WHE.
THIS L AD BAR OF
TOCONCER MEAN, IT'A BUILDI
ING TO DEFEN. IS SOATO BEGIN WI.
DE LOT OF IN
SCUFFLING,AYTSRE
THE LESSONFROMANUARY 6th ANDHATO
IGNORING THE WNIS THAT ARE
T TH
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT'S>>TELY.
TIONEDBIGGS, BUT
ICAN CONSMGGS TWEETING AER TWEEO
ACTION, FES FO PRESIDENT
UNITE
NOW, I J T THAT
CONGRESSMAN HIGGINS IS AN ARMY
VETERAN AN
LI
BUCKLE UP.U HEAR ANDY BIGGS TAL
ABOUWAYE FEYE,'S NOT M
TH COMOM ELECTEDOO W
OR ALLOW AND ENCOURAGE VIOLENCE?
BS
ANART OF THE
PLAYBOOKART
H WORKING WITH LOCAL
GO
AND THESWODANGEROUS THAN BRINGI
TO SOMETHISP THEIT'S HACT WORDS
WE'VE SEEN THIS TYPE OANUARY 6t.
EGO SEE
BEING
, POLIANAT
FOTHEY  HAVEN'TEEETORITOT ELECTE